this is the first direct image ever
taken of a black hole courtesy of the
event horizon telescope creating this
image required more data than any other
scientific experiment in history so how
did they do it
up until now most measurements of black
holes were indirect like this time lapse
of stars at the centre of our galaxy the
stars seem to be orbiting around
something something with a humongous
gravitational pool scientists predicted
that thing was a black hole astronomers
have also seen massive Jets of matter
emanating from the Centers of galaxies
sometimes much larger than the galaxies
themselves they predict that the only
thing powerful enough to create them
would be black holes the gravitational
waves detected by Lyell in 2015 where
the most direct and compelling evidence
for black holes today but detecting
gravitational waves is sort of like
fearing black hole scientists still
wanted to see it but how do you take a
picture of a black object against the
black background the answer backlighted
matter should emit radiation as it heats
up while circling the edge of a black
hole the event horizon with a big enough
telescope scientists should be able to
use that radiation as a backdrop to see
the silhouette of the black hole itself
but it's tricky even though the black
hole is gigantic and has galactic scale
impacts it is so far away to get an
image of high enough resolution
scientists calculated they'd need a
telescope the size of the earth which is
obviously impossible enter the event
horizon telescope which is not in fact
one telescope but a network of eight
observatories spread around the world
from Hawaii to Antarctica
each Observatory provides a tiny piece
of the puzzle take repeated readings as
the Earth spins and you can capture more
angles from each telescope once you have
enough pieces of the puzzle algorithms
can fill in the gaps and build up the
whole picture this process is called
interferometry the observations used to
create this image were made over a few
nights in 2017 each night each
Observatory gathered the same amount of
data as the Large Hadron Collider does
in a year and it has taken two years to
piece it all together with this image we
can see a black hole for the first time
but it's much more than images it
provides precise tests of reproductions
of general relativity and what's more
beyond the event horizon is a place
where physics as we know it no longer
works this is the first direct image
ever taken of a black hole but coded in
its pixels could be the answers to
questions about the hole
[Music]